hard at work
kip is a medical detection dog sniffing
out covert 19.
he's one of six dogs who have been
specially trained to detect the virus
and new findings have shown that up to
94
of the time they're accurate we've been
able to get
very good quality samples in front of
the dogs
in a in order they could learn this odor
very reliably
and they've even been able to do it with
with asymptomatic and mildly symptomatic
individuals
this is showing to be a disease with a
distinctive odor that
dogs can find and the fact they can find
it on a 50 pence piece of sock that was
worn
some time ago when it's presented to the
dog gives us
huge optimism that the dogs are going to
be able to do this
even better when they're able to smell
an individual walking past
in the past these dogs have been trained
to sniff out diseases like diabetes and
malaria
experts hope they'll now be able to play
a vital role in helping
fight the pandemic by providing rapid
screening in a way
other tools fail to do what we think is
that dogs could be an additional tool
that could be used as part of a kit
um to address the things that pcr
and lateral flow tests can't do so for
example dogs can screen people very very
quickly
so they could be used in circumstances
such as airports or other public
gathering stadiums that sort of thing
where lots of people have to be screened
very very quickly
the next phase of this research will see
the dog swap the labs for public places
to help see whether they're up for the
job aisha zahid sky news